as you know my good friend former Miss
Egypt of Los Angeles International and
you do comedian Sarah Basha and then and
then you oh my god I'm so excited also
miss Lebanon Los Angeles I just watched
your comedy special this morning and I
liked how he told a story of a girl
cheating on him and you kept saying a
woman always knows like you're calling
yourself a woman which I thought was the
final in deep inside I'm a woman you're
very sensitive thank you you are like
that's one of the things I first noticed
about being a woman is much more
superior than being a man and it's it's
you're stronger you're smarter so when I
say deep inside I'm a woman it's because
I take pride in being better than most
people oh we're going to get into that
but guys he's amazing if you don't know
him you have to check him out you have a
brand new special well how do they can't
get your special yet well yeah it's in
the process of finding a home but now
you can check you know Nimr yeah any
mr.and and and my clips are online and
EMR Nimr guys from lebanon he's amazing
i love you thank you for being here
again and also you're such a good friend
I love you so much every time we hang
out I'm like why don't I see him more
well Kate is in to point to say this
alpha top you're one of the very few
people when I first came to LA about
three years ago I ran into and you've
always been a very good friend to me as
well which is very rare in this industry
so thank you I really appreciate oh my
gosh well I'm trying to remember how we
met we met at Jon Lovitz comedy club you
were performing in a show exciting yes
night yeah yeah that's right and I was
on that show and I thought you were
hysterical not only did I win the crowd
that had come out to see me who had
never seen you before
all exclaim to me for like days on end
like that girl are you gonna do another
show with her are gonna do a thing I was
like you know maybe she should headline
next time Oh song no more oh no way you
sell like crazy so you're interesting so
okay Sarah and number I have never met
before which by the way if you you're
not single right now right no no longer
yeah I know I missed the boat with this
one I like I like how faith organized
this you know long after I found love
even though I was looking for so long
but nobody came and said hey here's a
suggestion that I found love like look
at these amazing lists of people every
time you and I have hung out I leave I
swear to God and I would talk to my
friends and go god I wish this guy
wasn't a comic because he's so hot and
so cool and so funny and like he like
it's so nice to me and then I'm like but
I can't say Tim sees a comic right
seriously well you have a no no comic
dating rules well I tried you have a
role but you break it okay I mean I have
dated a couple comics but like I really
try not to you know because it's you
know it's like dating in Korea and the
work other than the family well I mean a
family in the sense that you have to run
into these people a lot yeah like the
ones I've dated you know after it's been
over sometimes it's a little rocky yeah
I dream s probably [ __ ] where you
eat or reading where you sit
yeah it's like [ __ ] on your food
basically and then eating it which one
is worse sitting where you eat or eating
where you sit deciding where you I think
yes if you eat and then you take a dump
in the same area that's less than
actually you have any mentor taking a
[ __ ] in I think it depends on the order
if you're eating while jogging or if
you're [ __ ] and then eating in eejit
sorry guys I didn't mean it like right
this is a great you know it's very
investigated yeah style priorities like
we're out we are no longer sponsoring a
show or they could take advantage of a
clarity where the [ __ ] and I know that's
it was time but here's what's
interesting about you is so Nimr is like
a massive star in Lebanon he's like are
you like be honest so don't be humble
doubt when I ask you these questions
okay are you like can't walk the streets
famous like do you get stopped
constantly yeah but it's not like I
don't get stopped like Beyonce we get
stopped where it's like you can't walk
the streets you can walk the streets but
you need to take pictures oh it's a very
people have been in Lebanon and across
the Middle East so here I won't be
humble about that but the beautiful
thing about the Arabs is
and and uh and Sarah will know about
this they're very um what's the word I'm
looking for respectful so when they come
and they say hi to you in the street in
the way that somebody would hound us
somebody who's well-known in the Middle
East is different than I think here they
all like a man I love your work you know
they they they they open a really cool
conversation with you you get you know
take pictures and all that so it's never
been a it's never been I can't walk the
street I can but I get a lot of
compliments so that's nice it's like
being a hot chick yeah it is I got it
out you know and that's because of the
the bio Clippy I mean people just like
your skin that's pretty cool I mean has
anyone ever completely freaked out have
you ever had a fan that saw you that
like you're their Idol and they just
young younger younger fans will do that
I really yeah not all the time but I
mean if you know people are like 12-14
um cuz for them oh it's I think that the
wider the gap between seeing somebody
that you could be and being yourself the
more the freak out do you get what I'm
saying yeah so like when you're much
younger it looks like oh my god there's
no way I could ever like how was he able
to this was incredible then when you get
more familiar with the world and you
start to understand more about business
and stuff like that it doesn't become as
great it becomes more respect like I
really love how you stuck to your values
principles et cetera and and and ended
up standing for so I love what you do I
love your work and I'm glad to support
yeah because weren't you like the first
comedian out of Lebanon that's so crazy
as I am
isn't that wild it was fun did your dad
really in your special you talked about
your dad's reaction to wanting to do
comedy did your family really think it
was insane yeah that's amazing
well there are you I mean would your
family be supportive of an artistic
career from the get-go just straight up
Sarah yeah both my parents are very
supportive actually I was beautiful but
extension of the family not so
supportive my arms that's not really but
that's okay
are they supportive of of your your mom
and dad are they supportive like your
YouTube video stuff that you do yeah
they don't mind that I wear bikinis like
my aunt really minds but my mom and dad
doesn't mind and she like lives in a
bikini
by the way let me let me put this a
different way if you were doing what you
do here but in Egypt um
yeah my mom runs my Facebook page and
you don't think that it would have been
more difficult for you to do it in Egypt
than it would be to do here well I'm at
the thing is I'm actually more popular
in Egypt because when I won that I know
I didn't it was during the Revolution so
they kind of adopted you no no I know
that I thought I wasn't what I'm saying
is ironic is that parents will be easier
in general I guess not your case but in
general if you're like in Los Angeles or
outside of the country where people know
you personally then they then it's cool
like oh you know this is la this is how
you do it this is the thing but if you
were doing for me because my parents
were against because I was trying to do
it in the Middle East and they were
against it basically like not because of
any shame but nobody's done it how are
you gonna make a career out of it your
yeah morning English yeah yeah actually
I did try to do my career in Egypt for a
little while and just a language barrier
and accent is not too difficult so I
mean obviously I'm not going to go out
in a bikini but with the acting stuff
yeah I mean I could have done it it's
just it would have been like way harder
yeah because you have to break down
walls and barriers and set up the
industry yourself it's not like it's
later right right here to do it yeah the
issue my parents had with the comedy
kind of like okay you've graduated you
studied you've done this and now you're
going to go and do something that
doesn't exist
like what why just so that you could you
know be a clown my clown around have a
good time that that's what they
perceived it is what's amazing about you
though and I only know this from the
time that we've been friends is that you
built this whole career from nothing on
your own
like I think that's what's so amazing
like you didn't have like people know
there are no people that's what I'm I
didn't get any people until I came here
because I didn't know how to navigate
the industry here so you know the
manager the agent publicist that thing
happened here
but in the Middle East was the one-man
show you're the best example of how
someone because you could do that
theoretically yes
wherever you are yes you're such a great
example someone it was like I want to be
a comedian and then you basically built
the whole brand yourself you got your
spec didn't you find your own special
and everything and find my special pages
to put them out for free because I have
to understand it was a new art form and
for people to want to be encouraged to
go see the shows they needed to see a
sample so I would fill my specials put
them out on YouTube for free and then
people would watch them and then come to
the shows and then I'd film those with
bigger crowds and then put them out in a
bigger crowd and you know you have to
build it I took
amazing his especial car I mean just how
many people are at your his special are
thousands thousands of people are huge
but then the one you saw was massive I
mean that was the biggest one I did it
was in Beirut for five thousand people
in LA two thousand people that was the
one you were here in that tower just
crazy yeah crazy so cool
anyone well I think it's amazing I think
he's amazing you're amazing too Sarah I
don't mean that you know no you're
you're like I'm good I think it's so
funny that your little fans that are
like 12 and 14 love you so much because
I'm going to read you the kind of
messages I get from my young fans this
is from a kid that's 16 oh good he wrote
hi and then I didn't answer because it's
a DM and Instagram I'd see it and then a
month later he sent a heart emoji then I
still didn't see it and then another day
later he wrote [ __ ] you then I already
know you're a porn star so go die
sucking dick you ugly fat ass [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] that's my that's my fan mail I got
some ID on the other day I was in this
and what and then I thought to myself I
was going to post it up on my Instagram
so all my followers could like go it on
and horrible I know but then I looked at
his Instagram and he's 16 and I'm like
and he looks young he looks even younger
and I'm like why you why you being like
this so I want to say respectful to like
rah leaked his name is Radhika don't be
such a hater [ __ ] real Roly anyway I
learned some manners bros especially
when you're talking to women what's up
you know but if he was a teen and talk
to me that way
it might arouse me / I did you're not
confusing this young man right now rah
leaked the problem isn't how you're
talking to me it's that you talk to me -
two years like no I'm kidding don't talk
to women that way it's not only okay in
bed and even then only if they like it
the other day I was out on a date with a
guy and I asked him have you ever hit a
girl and he said please so you know only
if they ask me to and I was like oh I
love you anyway so on to you guys enough
about me I don't want to talk about bye
this is what's crazy about my dating
life right now
it's going so well that I don't want to
talk about it on here which I
you don't want to jinx I don't want to
jinx ad is so Arab it is that's a very
yeah I don't want to talk about
something cuz it'll we go they lie but
you live really like in in in in Lebanon
Sarah maybe I don't know if it's the
same ninja but I'm sure if you have like
a small you know kind of bumper to
bumper car accident car gets a bit
dented they'll leave it because it's a
it's better for the eye because that way
there's something distracting you so
let's say you have your phone and you
drop it in the screen cracks yeah don't
fix it because that way when people see
it it breaks the eye because they look
at it and they don't envy you as much
their focus of envy and hate is on
something I was like oh he cracked the
screen you just broken their ability to
focus their hate on you that's why I
have dings on all four sides of my car
just FYI I said I don't want anyone to
Envy me at all so I just have leave them
actually had a guy walk up to me one
time and he goes you know I I do
bodywork on cars and he saw this like
stuff on the front under my car goes I
could fix this for you make your car
really nice and I go really what about
the rest and he goes what do you mean I
go we'll walk around it he walked around
a seat
I have literally I just run into [ __ ] I
don't care how my car's paid off I run
into whatever I want
he walked around the car he goes yeah
you know it's probably not worth it for
you it's like it's not but anyway I
don't know I will give a brief update
because last week I talked about how I
I'm dating two guys I like both a lot so
I've been trying to figure out would you
listen to this podcast I hope no one I
know doesn't and one I think does
because one I asked him not to and
here's like I would never do that and I
believed them like the other one I
didn't bring it up and I'm pretty sure
he listened to it because he's kind of
low-key like quoted me my life but those
quotes were pretty generic statements
that I know I don't agree it doesn't
matter the point is it means interested
he listens yeah I know I told you yeah
my guys will do their research oh yeah
yeah yeah are you my knowledge of us do
you guys stop people social media the
way women I'm actually good about that I
don't do it because I I do it I do it
for her look of everything I like could
I don't like to look at people's social
media because it just I feel it just it
sets up
in my head sometimes that don't need to
be there so I just don't look if I like
somebody I don't usually even follow
them on social media I don't look at
their stuff at all rare because go find
things and then make themself upset I
don't want to make myself under that
because I get upset that is a man
approaches you always will check your
social media but the way we check your
social media is a totally I think
radically different way than a woman
what do you do well we take a look for
us to make sure that you're the person
we're talking to do you know what I'm
saying like we go onto your social like
let's say you're saying I'm Kay quickly
on the comedian I do this I do this I do
this then we go to your social media and
you've never posted anything about
comedy there's not then something a lot
of people I do that you know you want to
just make sure they're not straight up
liars yeah straight up lie like it's a
quick way but then we probably won't
continue to check unless we get really
interested seriously in which case we
want to see you know like is this person
going to really hurt me in the long term
it's a good way to know because men are
we get more we just do a better job of
covering it up but we get hurt just as
much as women if Elmore I don't know
about that I retired dated a guy and
then and then it ends and then he acts
like a complete you know dick and he
just doesn't talk to any goes and [ __ ]
somebody else behind your back and he
just he starts thrashing you on so
that's a man's way of being a gigantic
baby that's not a man's way of dealing
with it well or not he's the biggest
misperception is a woman who goes oh
he's over me he's moved on so quickly he
made it if you know that he moved on
quickly
that means you were very difficult to
get over because he's trying to make big
state now that's like the opposite of it
is oh well I guess yeah that's what
we've come to understand for women when
you move on quickly it devastates us
that's why we try to move on quickly so
we can devastate you too but that is
we're also [ __ ] we're [ __ ] because
that's all right it's a race but if you
don't know like if the guy actually
disappears and he's respectful and
everything that means you know then you
were easy to get over hmm I'm thinking
about it I think he did a last couple
guys that I've like ended stuff with and
how they moved on and what that means
cuz Sarah says that if a guy blocks you
you one yeah that's what she says she
that guy that's my point like if a dude
blocks you well yes if a guy blocks you
he one and then there's another breed of
guy like me who's just like okay that's
done out no point in
and carrying that with me and it's it
could be a second thought so it's not
necessary but it's definitely a good
indicator that you won because you got
to them but do you like to do you try to
stay friends with like I am no I don't
either
no no well I called at you're crossing
them out why on earth I don't understand
be more like I'm branding all my ex
there you go
you're the worst your little war so
listen wait just hold on with us first
of all I wouldn't say the word friend is
the right term but I'm cool with our
friend I'm cordial with all my exes like
I don't hang out with them a lot do you
guys text and like update each other my
ex-husband we talk every few months a
husband that's ever but even my ex like
boyfriends lovers guys I just hooked up
with anybody I've ever had any kind of
like sexual encounter with pretty much
wherever one sarong might say hey or
whatever but not like we don't go out to
lunch and stuff okay that's fair enough
that definitely not even close to
friends in that case but what do you
think it means if oh this is a good
question I didn't tell you about this I
have an ex boyfriend who we broke up
years ago like four years ago or
something and recently started texting
me again and you didn't live here but he
started texting me just casually like
talking and stuff and then he keeps
telling me I should like come visit oh
yes you don't burn the bridge they all
will come back I burn all my videos
maybe you write got such friends
no no way to fly somewhere like are you
leaving can I just say one thing about
guys yeah guys don't have many friends
most men have two or three great friends
and that's all we need we don't need
friends and we definitely don't need
girls as friends because you're
terrifying she went yeah went you guys
don't know I mean it when two guys hang
out right like take a sophisticated
conversation between two average men did
you [ __ ] her yeah was she hot dude her
ass insane awesome and they move on if
you have a woman man you say and she
says did you [ __ ] her and you go yeah
and she goes how was it what did she say
what happened afterwards I'll get us all
our insecurities women put out their
insecurities and deal with them men
shove them down we don't need women as
friends any guy who says oh I have a lot
of friends that our girls
due to has no game it's not a guy who
has so much game that girls want to be
his friend what about but you have
friends that are girls we're friends
we're friends I think is of the industry
being because I have a very similar kind
of thing that we were able to form a
friendship you're right but if I if it
was all due respect if I saw you in any
other circumstance if I just saw you
sitting across I wouldn't have looked at
you'd be like man I really want to get
to know who she is as a person my
initial thought would have been right I
mean my initial thought had been like I
hope she's a great person because I
would like to be with this woman for a
very long time that would be the law
yeah I get it I really do so I'm not
saying that men and women can't be
friends but if it happens it's not from
intent you're right because all the guys
that I'm friends with now like like one
of my very very best friends this guy
named Jackson do you know I'm Jackson
McWeeny the comic black guy and yeah
I've heard the me yes I tennis with him
a lot we yes I do when I first met him
you know it was in the context of like
he was like oh we should go out which
get drinks whatever but then we just
ended up becoming friends I think just
cause like we we didn't really have
chemistry yeah there I mean but later
the intention in the beginning was but
in you and Jackson are not friends like
you in serum right actually I pretty
much talk to him exactly the same way I
talked to a woman girl he gives me
advice on like all the guys I date he oh
god I'm not supposed talk about this no
right
just kidding he doesn't tell me anything
um no but he just he gives me you know
it's nice to have a guy friend you'll be
real with you about what guy think it is
you know we will be real that's for sure
yeah we're not we're not smart enough to
not be well I'm not friends with anyone
that I date date is fated or potentially
we're gonna date no you're not no you
know any exes I I don't have any guy
friends real I don't really have any guy
friends and I usually make it so they
don't want to be my friend after like
she really does she's like a little evil
she would do something so that I think
is completely stupid I just I'm a snitch
that's what I Sara the best because
she's petty as [ __ ] and she admits it so
if a guy like steps to her and basically
if they come at her and they don't
respect her and try to date her she puts
them in their place so hard and then she
finds ways to
basically like just [ __ ] with them for
fun that's well I mean there's a little
more to it but yes sir no no you know I
used all of the efforts that took the
high road and was like I'm going to be
mature about it but I'm like you know
what sometimes people need to put in
their place and I feel so much better
about it because I don't need whatever
you're doing makes you feel better than
do it well yeah but I mean I don't do it
like unwarranted like I don't go around
just like with a vengeance but no no
you're not being charged it looks
wonderful if a guy which this happens
all time in LA has a girlfriend
unbeknownst to me and I find out about
it that's what I will no comment I will
scare the [ __ ] out of them that is very
[ __ ] that is so common here I I mean
I'm not kidding
let me tell you something every guy I've
dated in the last probably three years
that I've been really into I have found
out has a girlfriend why on earth would
you get a girlfriend if you were also
interested in having other women just
don't I don't get it a girl I don't get
it the other thing I don't get is why
they don't put their girlfriend on
social media and I'm like I will figure
it out I I get that though because I
don't post pic I don't know you also
don't act single if you're in a
relationship like that I don't I mean
what is acting single like quotes and
stuff and women quote close yeah well
like you got a little caption oh I know
exactly like ladies come get it I am
like put up a picture of her but you
know like if they had puts up in their
story or no way rails you know what when
they don't like your pictures oh I can
notice all your stories I do no one
called that how about that I'm like
what's up with that if a guy it's very
weird if a guy I was talking to doesn't
follow me on social media I assume he
has a girlfriend
happy holiday you discover he's afraid
that if he follows me his girl what if
he's not following you because in
today's day and age following someone is
like taking a relationship to a serious
place is it I don't know I'm sorry
making our industry though I mean maybe
it's like your district but maybe some
people don't follow you for the same
reason I don't follow them you know it's
funny is like if someone will look at my
stories and they won't like my photos or
they won't follow but they'll go like
like one photo just let me know they're
there and if a girlfriend I'll block
them and I'll tell them I would lock
eyes are insane no I don't realize it
could be a guy
who just doesn't really isn't that
active on zone oh okay let me tell you I
feel like you're what I'm saying is that
you're well this could because of the
way la has treated you guys and maybe
this is more your experience but there
are also guys out there who are just
basic dudes who are like [ __ ] I should
just like a picture just so she knows
that I like her stuff but he doesn't
really but why wouldn't you follow you
know he should yeah no Carlos I have a
question so there was an Egyptian guy in
New York you know I keep trying fire
Egyptian people there's Lee why we're in
danger sweetie are you supposed to date
an interruption is awesome I just I
don't know I don't know it's gonna make
my life more difficult so you know so I
saw him and we actually did telephone
numbers you know we went online or
whatever and he looks at all my stories
will not look like a single photo he
follows me but well not like a single
photo not comment nothing and then time
goes on and then I unfollow him he was
like oh you went falling like yeah
because when my song before you know and
then I told him I'm like do you have a
girlfriend and he said no I don't and
I'm like okay so have me not liking my
photos and he doesn't answer
oh now I know what you're saying I never
thought of that yeah because petroleum
is your if he likes your photo than his
girls they could see it sometimes so
late and I only know I actually being a
man is often think of that angle this
whole our schedule or saying I'm like oh
he just doesn't follow you and now I'm
like cats are saying could it be I'm
good at me who can stock the caddy you
like will see that activity will put
some of you together and Sarah is CEI
intelligence and intelligence she did
intelligence the military said in like
she's like CIA on these [ __ ]
like okay here's the thing
Sarah's a more normal chick I would say
I'm like I am very very super sensitive
that's my biggest like downfall with
guys I'm so sensitive I take a lot of
[ __ ] personally that I shouldn't but I
don't go down the path of like crazy
stalking like a lot of women do but
Sarah is much more common women go
co-teachers not always and I do that
because I like I'm sick I can't remember
the last guy data that was completely
single I really can't I just write what
is that maybe it's maybe that means you
you're looking in the wrong place
because if it's a common thing there has
to be good guys out there I met a well
there are there in LA yeah but not here
how would you know any she's like me do
you have friends because you're cute do
you have friends just like you he's
really thinking my friends are God
all my friends are in relation to my
proper committed I don't know what was
already always is that guys in our
industry don't want stable relationships
which I've been surprised because I'm
the opposite for me it's like there's so
much volatility in what we do I'd love
to have at least one thing that's just
for me that's that is exactly how that's
exactly how I feel and people don't get
it people are like why do you want I'm
like I just want one thing that at the
end of the night is stable stable boy
cuz you said no matter what goes on the
ups and downs during the day you come
home yeah and there's there's that
constant I have that but but you're
aware because here's the thing I know
that but I don't understand why it's
rare because I know there's this whole I
think it's just been so hyped up the
single life and that you can like I can
have so many girls and I could do this
but it's actually exhausting to have to
put yourself out there over and over and
over again I personally think it has a
lot to do with insecurity I don't with
all social media stuff so people have
become really insecure and it became a
way of world getting to get you where
you get me you know I went to you though
like I would think like I'm not a man
but I can say as a woman like and I
don't mean this to sound arrogant but I
was thinking about it today like today I
walked to 7-eleven and back to my
apartment which is a two block walk and
three guys hollered at me like a guy on
a skateboard and then a homeless guy
minor and a regular guy get items all
socials okay yeah alright but the point
is I thought to myself like I rolled my
eyes at the third guy because I was just
like annoyed as [ __ ] and I mean it's a
nice thing for people to think that
you're attractive whatever but like from
a woman's perspective it's like it gets
annoying when people are constantly
coming up to you because you just don't
know like who is generally genuinely
interesting getting that who just wants
to [ __ ] you whatever but I would think
is a guy it would be exhausting on the
other side trying to juggle more than
one chicks because I'm able to crazy it
a chicks are crazy and we're not
equipped mentally to be able to handle
many women that's why if you were lucky
enough to find one amazing woman that
would be stupid enough to spend her life
with you why on earth would you not want
that yeah no one would be stupid to be
with you though that's what you say but
here's the thing look I think I do a
really good job of being attendant of
being a good person because I've always
wanted that one thing I've always I've
shaped myself to be a kind of guy you'd
want to spend your life with you that's
what I want but you also lived in Italy
for a while so yeah way I might make it
like Middle Eastern men in general are
hot lemony I love Italy is any judgment
there good law but there also I mean
maybe because where we grow up in a
society and a culture where everybody
knows everyone screwing around is going
to get around a lot quicker and the
repercussions are a lot bigger of all
women in Lebanon so let's say you're a
fuck-boy right which I know is a common
term here some women find that
attractive in the Middle East if youre a
fuccboi and war gets out you're not
going to each over for you any girl
that's shut out I'm moving I think it's
I think it's glorified here wait girl
fight here it's over there it's a
disaster because every girl I've known
big girls I've dated girls that I know
girls I work with though be this like
genuinely hot stud model dude who's like
hitting him up and I'm like hey what you
got he's trying to it she's like aw he
does that with all the women [ __ ] him
and and they avoid him like kryptonite
yes that's how I am now I don't care who
you are I had a guy there was a guy in
town a few weeks ago really hot guy
total stud all my guy friends were like
you have to hook up that my guy friends
like please welcome and tell us about it
yeah I'm not kidding here his moves with
us yeah and so this guy asked me to do
something and long story short I want to
do it with I want to hang with him and
she's our late like he kept me waiting
for an hour and then you know what I
just I left left
I just left yeah and all my guy friends
thought I was insane no guy friends your
guy friends Ernie or idiot they're
idiots right they're absolutely you are
my thing isn't like I don't care who you
are I don't care how hot you are I don't
care
great your dick is I don't give a [ __ ]
if you don't treat women well 20 30
years no matter how hot we are no matter
how great our dick is no matter how
great anything like that is it's it
really you could be you know Clark Kent
after 20 30 years it's it's not the the
Clark Kent that's going to keep you it's
the it's not chemistry it's the law so
you got it
it's weird people work on the wrong
facets of being attractive and really
the attractive there's a difference
between being attractive for right this
second and being attractive or right to
second for the next 60 trillion seconds
I agree so I'm the kind of guy who's
like if you can find a girl who's
beautiful attractive smart funny that
you don't have to go and do stuff with
to have a good time where you could
literally just sit down and hang out on
a couch in silence and kind of just be a
dress and happy yeah Tenali then let
that go and until you find that don't
stop trying is it sad that he's taken
well she's lucky I know I know trust me
I'm lucky but if it dull oh okay then
when she watches this he is gonna get so
late oh no ask you fine so she's like
you of course you're lucky we're not but
what about why didn't you sit no no not
at all but um I'm like this because I
look at my parents and I look at other
happy couples and I see what makes it
unclick and I'm like okay so if I want
to be happy it's easy you got to do this
I'm confused why people here have yet to
piece together that if you want to be
happy don't be a [ __ ] and I don't see
why I would okay well people yeah
illegitimate children and other problems
no no why
yeah yeah get a family my dad told me
something once which was incredible my
mom and my dad like I've never met
people who don't have here I mean zero
trust issues like if somebody could call
my mom up and say uh you know Joseph is
is banging this chick into saying it and
and she would she would there's pictures
wouldn't prove it like she didn't know
if not all and I and I used to and my
dad told me something he said but you
should know that if I when I married
your mom I always thought to myself that
if the woman I marry not your mom but if
the woman I marry ever cheats on me this
is a very powerful sentence he said I
still wouldn't get a divorce and I said
why wouldn't you get a divorce and he's
because I got married for my family I
didn't get married for me and he said
getting a divorce would bring
instability to my children that's a guy
who I look at unlike his priorities for
getting into a relationship and my mom
as well
were different they were like who is the
perfect person that wouldn't cheat on me
so that I could where I have a stable
family for the next 60 years whereas
other people are like oh man this girl's
so hot she's of wine I got a [ __ ]
barrier or my relationship is getting a
bit stale maybe if we get married it'll
kick spice things up maybe we get a kid
in whoo I said that because my dad I was
with my cousin in New Jersey and he
showed a picture of this girl she was
really pretty girl he's like what do you
think about her because he's looking to
get married
and my this goes like tons of makeup and
I mean she's hot
super hot and my dad said that's a girl
you date not going nah girl you married
yes because she's hot well I mean he was
a it but it's a type of because she's
putting I'll tell you what he was
thinking he's taking a look at a picture
of a girl who's putting a picture online
of herself having done a lot of makeup
and constantly putting out an image out
there that means for her what matters is
not experience but image right if you
want to get married you don't get
married to somebody who cares about
image you get married to somebody who
cares about substance so we're going to
be single forever we need to say hey
well I trust I'll a something cake on
all your captions on all your people not
all because there's some that you do
just to mess around but on a lot of your
captions and stuff you write are [ __ ]
hilarious and very smart
thank you so any guy who looks at is
like she's a really hot girl who's also
very funny and smart and everything so
it's a [ __ ] but if you're just putting
up those pictures where you look like
and the caption is believing yourself
don't you oh my god oh my god I get the
[ __ ] shares my judge long duration of
my stupid don't let anybody ever tell
you can't do like what you look good
follow your dreams [ __ ] that noise
techno that's exactly that's [ __ ] so
no that doesn't apply to us I mean it is
funny though because I do think and a
lot of my I mean my mom a lot of my
friends have said that to me they go you
know I think the reason that guys in
take you surly is your social media
people say to me all the time and I'm
like what am I supposed to do about that
it's a brand I can't but that is the
reason why and this is funny I was
talking about this with someone the
other day I don't Google anyone I do
ever she does I know and most people do
well done I don't ever Google the guys I
go out with because I feel like if
someone Google's me they go oh this
chicks and be like just down to bang
she's gonna stay and listen in my pocket
they're going to go I do is [ __ ] and
then I'm crazy and I do all this wild
[ __ ] but then if they really get to know
me I'm so kind of chill and you're okay
you should Google because the difference
between you and the other people is that
this is your job and your industry and
your brand which you're selling a dude
who works as an accountant or financial
representation of like I well then you
should definitely be googling them no no
because I believe they're men I dated
this guy and I mean especially their man
can be simin can be weird women you can
find a woman that has goes to church
every Sunday is the she all her poster
about Jesus and she's the biggest [ __ ]
you've ever met and then you can find
out right now with a guy you will see it
coming from mile away take a look at any
guy you I can point out to you without
fail who is a [ __ ] boy who isn't
immediately I'd really because you know
what I'm gonna let you start googling
the guys I date former I don't like to
do it also because it hurts I don't want
em I like listen to Sheriff like there
was a guy that I dated honestly if I had
researched some of the first guy that
I've ever dated I would have saved
myself a lot of counsel in time but I
remember one guy after I dated him I
started looking at his clothes I started
reading the comments and I saw the way
he was talking to women and I was like
this side you know I had looked in the
beginning I would've known from the jump
this guy to not respect women did not
take him seriously I guess I should you
can't change people I think the biggest
weird thing that I see in relationships
people are like yeah you know but he'll
change it no he or she will not change
you did I agree with that zapped ability
I agree right there's a bit of a ting
that will happen little habits that
might change like if you okay just close
the you know put down the toilet seat
when you're done that kind of stuff but
but if somebody isn't honest it's not
going to change because of you I agree
with you I paid dodges attempt I don't
think a tiger I've been talking about
this because I told her I've dated a
couple guys that I think are trying
really hard tonight yeah I don't think
yeah Oh a tiger doesn't change its
stripes like
I've dated a couple guys that I think
are trying really hard to be what they
think I want like they're trying I can
see how hard you're doing work so yeah
but I think it's like that what is that
that thing I always say the Scorpion and
the have you are all or something yeah
it's not a squirrel and like a duck or
something come on what no I like this
story I forget what the animals there's
an animal in water let's just say it's a
duck ugly duckling Anna and the farm
ruffian needs a ride across the river
and the duck says I'm not giving you
ride your scorpion you'll sting me and
the Scorpion says if I sing you will
both die and the duck goes good point
hop on and scorpion gets on then halfway
across the river
it stings a duck and they both die and
the duck goes why did you do that any
sex I'm a scorpion similar nature but
that's what I think I think you can't
change your base NATO you can't yeah I
shall agree like it's a different
perspective think about how hard it'd be
for you to change yourself you know yeah
very
maybe when you're 13 right people change
but when you're 30 when you're 25 not a
problem but I'm just now doing a lot of
like self-help work and I think I'm
changing
no what you're doing they are really
improving no no you're doing yeah
improving yeah but you're still Kate
Quigley who likes these things you're
still quite clearly who admires these
traits and you're but what you're doing
is you're improving
if the royalty was important to you in
the past is going to be important to you
now if loyalty wasn't important to you
in the past it's not going to be
important to you now even if you
convince yourself that it is
philosophically your temptations and
your urges will take over that's a good
point
damn I'm learning a lot today this is
like I feel like this is like a therapy
session
almost these are we're taking date fails
and to date successes I I'm uh I'm sad
because we only have like 10 minutes I
could talk to you forever but before we
move on I have one more ads that I have
to do is do it I have one more ad this
is a good one because uh I got a new
mattress I'm really dude yeah these
people woke me up you have a mattress
yes the main room you got to come over
and you can spend the night you can
spend the night well yeah I'll jump on
the masters together I'm gonna go test
it out it's a Casper mattress have you
heard of it I
I've been sleeping on cast four
mattresses nice and flat funny it's
amazing since before the Internet is
anything where I was born
that's why my skin look I just want to
say that everyone knows mattresses are
overpriced this is true mattresses are
so overpriced like it's ridiculous it's
coughing Springs I know it's insane and
then the reason is because the mattress
industry you know it forces consumers to
pay a lot because things are marked up
in the stores and Casper has
revolutionized the industry by cutting
the cost of dealings dealing with the
showrooms so you don't get this in a
showroom you get it online yeah you get
it online it's completely risk-free you
go online by the way Casper what's cool
about it is that it combines memory foam
and and it's got like a cooling quality
you don't sweat on these mattresses
it keeps you cool you can have sex on it
like is that like I haven't tried that
conditioning at this bathroom
it's beautiful we have your deal anyway
listen guys it's risk-free this is
what's cool you you buy it online it's
free delivery free return and you get a
hundred night in-home trials you can
actually use it for a hundred nights if
you don't love it you can send it back
for free because Casper understands how
important it is to sleep on a mattress
before you commit just like Jenna sleep
before you commit Roo I know you believe
in that I believe in that from your
special not from personal yeah oh yeah
anyway so guys I want you to check it
out
like I said Katherine mattress they
deliver everywhere they're actually the
top number one reviewed mattress on the
internet which is amazing and you can
get it at what's the website Casper comm
backslash date sales you got a hit
backslash date fails they'll give you
$50 towards any mattress you purchase so
it's Casper comm backslash state fails
make sure you guys check that out if you
need a mattress Sarah I can't give you a
free mattress but I can probably get you
hooked up somehow you might want to cut
the holes no sweat it's really nice
because you don't sweat on it a lot down
your foot on top of my shitty mattress
yeah him up there is something I wanted
to ask you because like you're such a
solid guy and you're all about love and
relationships and like Jesus he's it not
necessarily but yeah that's a great
question I need to know are you Jesus up
my Deschanel yeah there was a boy
where you went from being a normal guy
to being a famous guy at least in the
Middle East so did you go through any
kind of crazy like wild like I can get
any chick I want phase where you just
banged out a bundle funny thing is get
money I got very famous as a comic and
it took a few years after that until I
felt comfortable speaking to women I
think that's the funny thing
oh I was never in college getting more
and more perfect no no but I mean I was
I was very I used to be why deny date
him I got it
we believe oh my language this is not
bad it's a biased representation I'm
giving it myself but the map I can't
tell you how many times I liked girls
any clue over my head completely that
they were also interested in me and I
look at the cringe I get just thinking
about things I did wear like years later
I'd be sitting at home and then I'd be
like oh my god like oh my that's what's
cool and just like and I'll be like why
did she just stop talking why was she
being so mean and then it because I
totally rejected her not realizing me
that I was even rejecting her I could
give you like just the most
cringe-worthy just like oh they hurt
guys are so naive to when women like
Chuck Berry I was back in a hurry I was
back in Ohio I ran into a guy named Mike
who I went to high school with he was a
senior when I was a freshman I ran into
him at like a gas station like a year
ago and I was like man I go I had the
hugest crush on you in high school all
through high school and he was like what
yeah I'm like how could you not know I
literally would find out where this guy
hangs out though and just show that I
started smoking to impress this guy like
everything I did was for this guy and he
had no idea do you remember Jim Jimmy
found in Nicole Kidman that that
interview that went viral I don't know
I'm sorry it's hysterical you have to
watch it if you haven't watch it
together it's probably one of his almost
watched clips Nicole Kidman goes on his
show tells him about the time she had a
crush on him and she went to his house
he looks the look the genuineness of the
moment he loses his mind he said wait
wait wait what he's like you came to my
house because you because you wanted to
get to know me and she's like yeah he's
like why is he the what
and this Jimmy Fallon why do you think
she came over he had no idea but to us
in Everett her suicide a woman that
beautiful right like that guy in your
high school must have thought you were
the bomb like why would she wanted me
and why would she be interested in me
that's so funny because I think that if
you even smile at a guy he's like she
wants to fall yeah now because we're so
stupid and we've been conditioned by the
internet to talk like that but go back
and rewind to when were first started I
mean you asked when I got fake I got
super famous at the age of like 23 24
and I wasn't intellect 25 26 where I was
like comfortable walking up to girl and
then I had a huge breakthrough when I
used to do phone taps which were how I
got famous in the Middle East immunity I
used to do pranks mm-hmm and I call
these women up to do a prank because I
was acting a character I wouldn't be
nervous talking to women yeah and I
would end up charming them and I used to
be like well if you just confidently
talk to a woman it seems to work it was
like a breakthrough and then I go to a
bar walk up to grow and be like hey
how's it going my name is Nimr what's
your name and he would work and I'd be
like oh my goodness like yeah it could
all be so simple but we go example it is
so subjective a guy just comes up to you
with confidence and it just treats you
like a normal human again that's pretty
only oh my god I've unlocked the key but
it was and I'll tell you then I got
excited I was like not that I could have
any woman that I want but I can talk to
any woman that I want and then hopefully
you'll go from there and then it was
just like I've been in steady
relationships my life looking for the
right one and in between of course
dating but I never did anything super
crazy yeah you are always like so
respected I can't tell you like you're
one of the few male comics like there's
a handful that never like made a pass
and we never hit them and I always
noticed those guys I'm like oh they're
really like good like you're just like a
great well because I can also imagine
that I used to when I first started
hanging out with you I would be a bit
careful because I was like she's a very
beautiful woman I'm sure a ton of guys
do that and I want her to know that I
value her as a person so it was in the
beginning I was a bit cautious and then
I was like oh you're very easy to talk
Thanks no but Kate is I mean you can I
mean most girls are in general you talk
to if your intentions are clear from the
beginning right right I her and I have a
theory that like if they screw us over
we're going to talking about them or
something online or something
Oh what do you mean like a guy if they
look like sometimes they stay away
because like they see our social media
like you were saying earlier intimidated
Oh guys yeah but I just
you want the guy for you the guy for you
the guy who wouldn't be intimidated by
your social media who would understand
what it is so don't not be yourself and
try to snag the guy you come along and
just don't don't lose them yeah there's
there's I said there was two guys that I
was like seeing and and so guys in a
girl yeah but um everything the one guy
or details yes I actually said to him
because I'm Memorial Day I posted a
photo I was at Bravo Williams house my
friend Brad place for a party Auto
sbrick Brad and uh and that I said to
Brad would it be funny if we took a
photo or me and my girlfriend or both
topless and we're hanging out at your
pool and it just looks like it's a
topless party but we're just like
chillin talking like just to make it so
he's like yeah so we did this photo from
we're all top with him and I just put
like you know stickers over over my
boobs over everybody's boobs Brad's too
and Fisher was hilarious thank you it
was a funny photo but what I liked is
that guy he liked the photo the guy
Vince Ian and I noticed that he liked it
and I went really love that that he's
not jealous he's not weird about it if
he didn't freak about it yeah I love me
most guys who do stuff like that mean
that they're going to give you the
benefit of the doubt they're gonna give
you the chance I want to add like
especially for us who are in the
industry and like we do get sponsorships
off our engagement that's another reason
why I tell guys like hey if you're not
liking my stuff you're essentially not
supporting my career true and that's who
you are I agree I mean if I didn't you
know I wasn't having it to social media
what really matter as much true it's
true well I'm sad that we have to end
this because it went so fast it went uh
Erin you got another pod coming in right
now right yeah we got to cut it dance
well on those this is a blast when you
come back new this Brandi I'd love to
you're so great thank you gave so much
insight I just I want to hear more like
horror stories from your past I know
there's got to be great ones but there
are but I did a good job of
circumventing you really guide I want
you to make sure you follow Nimr your
twitter handle is at NIMH or comedy and
II M our comedy is that your Instagram
as well
everything website the whole deal
everything YouTube watch a specialty so
funny I can't wait for you to sell the
special I watched his new special it's
fantastic I'm going to watch on Arabic
so I can brush up on my
in English but I mean you don't have
anything on there you know all my
stand-ups always been oh I'm not gonna
wash them and and this comes out
tomorrow so are you the laughs actors
week and again tomorrow and after
tomorrow at the Laugh Factory Friday
night Friday night and Saturday night
10:00 p.m. show on Friday 9:00 p.m. show
on Saturday boom and guys I am at the
Brea improv this weekend with Joey Diaz
so come on out check that out if you
want to sarah facha follow her at Sarah
Pasha check out her YouTube at Sarah
Pasha TV we just released the first
episode of [ __ ] boy Patrol so you can go
watch that on her youtube channel as
well and make sure you check out my
patreon support the podcast it's
patreon.com slash Kate q funny buy a
mattress and buy some skin care and this
can care on your face yeah all right
later guys bye